shortly after the death of a baby She's
accused of murdering Lucy let B message
to friend to say it was fate that babies
got unwell sometimes the prosecution say
it was bad luck or fate for that baby
that Lucy letby was on duty that night
on the second day of her trial the court
continued to hear details of the short
lives of the 17 babies She's accused of
murdering or attempting to murder
the jury was told about a baby
identified as child e his mother went to
visit him and his twin in the neonatal
unit at the Countess of Chester Hospital
Nicholas Johnson KC told the jury that
she interrupted Lucy letby who was
attacking child e although she didn't
realize it at the time
the baby was distressed and bleeding
Lucy letby said trust me I'm a nurse
that's what she told her Mr Johnson said
child e died and the court heard Lucy
letby took an unusual interest in his
family researching them on social media
in the weeks after his death even on
Christmas Day
the day after she allegedly murdered
child e the prosecution say she
attempted to murder his twin brother
the jury was also told about a baby
identified as child C born premature but
in good condition when the nurse looking
after him left his room she heard an
alarm and returned to find Lucy let be
standing by his incubator Lucy ledby
should have been looking after a
different baby at the time and had been
told off for ignoring an order to do so
the prosecution say she texted an
off-duty colleague to say she wanted to
be in the room with child C because it
would be cathartic good for her
well-being to see a living baby in a
space previously occupied by a dead baby
that was child a who she's also accused
of murdering the prosecution say Lucy
let be killed child C by injecting air
into his stomach there was a pattern a
method of attacking babies was
developing Mr Johnson told the jury if
you're trying to murder a baby in a
neonatal unit it's a fairly effective
way of doing it it doesn't really leave
a Trace
the prosecution say Lucy letby also
attempted three times to kill a baby
girl identified as child G she survived
but has irreversible brain damage the
common presence in these incidents the
prosecution say was Lucy leppi she
denies all 22 charges she faces and the
trial continues Greg Milam Sky News
Manchester